merci de nous rejoindre sur tv soixante
dix huit pour cette nouvelle édition de
votre journal d'actualités locales nous
sommes le mercredi 7 novembre et voici
les sujets qui seront développées ce
soir 3e édition du sky business dès
demain jeudi au vélodrome nationale à
montigny le bretonneux rendez vous qui
doit permettre aux grands groupes et aux
pme tpe de faire des affaires les enjeux
avec erwan le gall conseiller
communautaire de l'agglomération délégué
à l'emploi et à l'insertion
professionnelle
nous poursuivrons notre dossier consacré
cette semaine à la pénurie de médecins
quelle solution à les communes mettent
elles en place éléments de réponse au
cours de cette édition et puis la
musique avec général elektriks le groupe
de musique électro pop sera sur la scène
au prisme à elancourt le 13 novembre un
documentaire qui lui est dédié sera
projeté juste avant au ciné 700
réalisateur va nous rejoindre en plateau
à la société du grand paris en charge du
super métro autour de la capitale va
voir ses ressources augmentées de plus
de 100 millions d'euros dès l'an
prochain l'information a été donnée
aujourd'hui par nos confrères des échos
et qui évoque une hausse de la taxe
pardon sur les bureaux à paris et dans
les hauts-de-seine une taxe également de
séjour régionales devraient voir le jour
objectifs permettent le financement d'un
chantier estimé à quelques 35 milliards
on reste dans l'économie permettre la
rencontre entre les entreprises de saint
quentin pour qu'elles puissent faire des
affaires c'est la promesse de
l'événement sky business day qui revient
demain jeudi 18 novembre
on saura à roanne le gall bonsoir et
bienvenue vous êtes maire-adjoint de
maurepas conseiller communautaire
délégué à l'emploi notamment à
l'agglomération de 50 ans ce sera la
troisième édition de cet événement au
vélodrome nationale et déjà c'est un
succès en termes d'inscrits et le bouche
à oreille des années précédentes a été
plutôt bon wes très favorable et avec la
particularité qu'on a ouvert aussi sur
en dehors de 50 ans donc c'était aussi
un challenge et challenges eux de
transformer une vraie réussite donc on a
à peu près un taux de 59 60 % de 2,2
d'une structure d'entreprise sur saint
quentin qui sont en crise et en dehors
40%
donc c'est ce que tu viens tu as un
tournoi un nombre total d'entreprises
sur sa crainte après cinq entreprises
qui sont présentes
l'événement ait été sur inscription
alors il n'est pas ouvert au public
le but c'est que les entreprises se
rencontrer puis qu'ensuite ça débouche
sur des emplois
c'est aussi ça mais là c'est de prendre
à la base des grands groupes des pme tpe
tous types d'entreprises sont présentes
tout à fait vous l'avez souligné le but
s'est rendu sur la vague du bi tube i 1
c'est du business to business c'est
entre des grands comptes qui rencontrent
des pme ou des tpe des tpe qui
rencontrent des pme donc le principe
c'est vraiment de favoriser les échanges
économiques au travers un lieu dédié
qu'il vélodrome
à un moment donné et de transmettre
aussi de savoir au lieu d'aller chercher
parfois du business en dehors du
territoire et bien des fois c'est
apporter ou même le voisin à face
d'entreprise mais elle pratique quelque
chose que je recherche
voilà donc c'est ça l'idée et ça se
faisait pas avant les entreprises n'ont
pas le réflexe forcément d'aller voir le
grand groupe va pas voir ce que fait la
petite tpe/pme juste à côté et qui
pourrait l'aider à avancer
alors ça on ça change quand même ça
change et en plus nous avons localisé un
village d'innovation ça c'est une
première
donc il y aura une petite vingtaine de
start up donc qui ont qui vont démontrer
faire des démonstrations sur pas mal de
choses donc là aussi les grands comptes
pourront regarder ce que font ces start
up et certaines start up viennent de ski
cube évidemment voyants sont les
secteurs les plus dynamiques
actuellement ou pour le business des par
exemple alors sur le secteur ce qu'il y
est
au niveau des inscriptions moi je suis
allé voir c'est un panel très large
voilà donc je crois que tout le monde
c'est vrai c'est retrouver là-dedans
vous avez services bancaires vous avez
les services automobiles
vous avez les tpe/pme de l'assurance aux
services à la personne
je pense à cette start up au d'avila qui
est sûr ce ti culs qui elle aussi va
rechercher certainement deux ou trois
contacts pour développer son activité au
sein du département
voilà il ya un pad est tellement large
que tout le monde s'y retrouve vous
évoquez ce qui cube le but vraiment pour
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines s'est accompagnée de la
création presque de l'entreprise et
jusqu'à ses premières à faire son
business sont les accompagnons on aide
au développement au sein du ski cuves et
puis ensuite on les accompagne lors du
sky business day pour qu'elle rencontre
d'exact le 11 est la particularité de
cette année c'est que en plus le public
pourra par rapport aux démonstrations et
voir dans le village de l'innovation ce
qui leur plaît et voter et l'heureux élu
aura la chance de briller et est en tout
cas d'avoir un niveau de communication
élevé et surtout un film réalisé sur son
activité
voilà lorsqu'elle des échanges comme ça
entre les grands groupes les pme ça dure
quoi une vingtaine de minutes c'est très
pro nommé trait à celle assez précis ces
trente minutes mais le temps qui est
l'échangé la mise en place s'est on est
dedans
bravant dans la rencontre ces 25 minutes
on a 25 minutes pour essayer de
convaincre et dans de son produit essayé
très des relations mais alors on est
vrai c'est jean sisto bien sûr beach oui
on n'est pas dans le recrutement
vous avez à faire c'est deux chefs
d'entreprise qui se rend compte donc ils
parlent le même langage
25 minutes je vous assure moi je suis un
peu là dedans ça va très vite mais en
même temps on va à l'essentiel et c'est
bien c'est vraiment serbe on forme
vraiment vous avez pu faire un bilan des
deux précédentes éditions
combien de contacts ont pu être noués
est-ce que ça a débouché sur des vrais
contrats des échanges concrets entre ces
groupes alors avec des stades précise
déchiffrer
eco je les ai pas moi je pense que
l'indicateur qu'il faut prendre
c'est troisième édition plus
d'entreprises un vrai engouement et tous
les chefs d'entreprise que l'on croise
dans notre activité de saint quentin
c'est que il nous parle du seuil
business day ils ont des contacts
ils transforment leur leurs contacts
avec des contrats donc c'est que ça
fonctionne bien si la courbe s'est
inversée c'est à dire qu'on est on
serait autre tentation de 300 à 200
puissant on devrait s'inquiéter c'est
pas le cas du tout et comme je l ai dit
en introduction c'est qu'en plus ouverts
à en dehors de saint quentin les
entreprises viennent
ça veut dire que ils savent qu'il ya un
enjeu économique très fort mais une
vraie puissance ne faut pas l'oublier un
jeu pour ensuite déboucher sur de
l'emploi c'est nécessaire et oui et 7
buts aussi une activité échos qui
fonctionne qui génère évidemment de
l'emploi et qui arrive aussi à embaucher
au niveau du bassin mais aussi en dehors
du bassin parce qu'il ya les entreprises
du bassin peel et les gens aussi qui
travaillent et vivent pardon sur le
bassin et qui ont peuvent trouver une
activité en dehors de l'agglomération de
saint quentin ce rendez-vous le sky
business day sera aussi l'occasion pour
l'agglomération présenter aux
entreprises les différents services qui
existent oui il ya mis en place pour
elle tout à fait tout à fait ça il ya
comme tous les ans je viens
quelles sont les choses innovantes sur
lesquels vous allez mettre l'accent
cette année peut-être quand je vous dis
on est très axée sur l'innovation
1 ça c'est quelque chose qui est
vraiment important et puis je crois que
il est bon de rappeler
de ce que l'on fait tout au long de
l'année ont fait énormément de choses je
peux vous dire que on est regardés
nationalement l'agglomération est très
très dynamique sur le plan des
donc c'est important aussi
sans partir sur des visions à 2020 2022
le rappelait déjà ce que l'on fait
vraiment moi je vais juste rappeler que
il ya en piste pour l'emploi deuxième
échéance le 4 avril 2019
voilà ça c'est une une perspective qui
arrivent et qui est précis ce qui est
clair c est programmée merci erwan le
gall la convention d'affaires sky
business day se tiendra donc le 8
novembre à saint quentin en yvelines au
vélodrome et nous y reviendrons bien
évidemment dans ce journal et puis dans
un prochain numéro de notre magazine
économique merci à vous merci
la dernière information concernant
l'emploi le département lance jobs 78
est une plateforme internet afin de
permettre à la mise en relation entre
employeurs du département et
bénéficiaires du rsa un algorithme une
géolocalisation permettent de mieux
cibler les demandes les exigences de
chacun l'adresse internet s'affiche sur
votre écran une application pour
smartphone et en développement jobs 78
point fr
les commémorations du centenaire de la
grande guerre se poursuivaient à
versailles c'est une exposition sur les
lendemains à de la victoire et qui est
proposé des documents d'archivés ou
encore des documents issus et des
greniers et des habitants sont à
découvrir marylène yapi chez nous et
patrick jacques de dixmude le 11
novembre 1918 l'armistice était signé
mais la grande guerre laisse ses traces
certains soldats mettent plusieurs mois
revenir des tranchées et la vie
quotidienne reste difficile c'est cette
période que la ville de versailles et le
comité des anciens combattants ont
choisi de mettre en avant dans leur
exposition versailles au lendemain de la
victoire de 1918
j'ai voulu me décaler un petit peu en
présentant la prémisse this pour
démontrer d'une part que les soldats ne
sont pas revenus
enfin 18 mai beaucoup
minh 19 voire plus tard et puis nous
avons voulu quand même personnaliser
cette exposition par des par une
présentation de documents appartenant
aux familles versaillaise des documents
qui s'ajoutent à ceux des archives
municipales départementales et
enrichissent l'exposition
là vous avez un document qui est assez
rare qui est une lettre à l'encré
sympathique de façon à contourner les
censures souvent donc les soldats des
poilus écrivait alors famille avec de
l'encré sympathique était révélé ce
travail est aussi intergénérationnel
depuis plusieurs années une
collaboration se fait avec les collèges
et les lycées du département
leurs productions font pleinement partie
de l'exposition et présentent leur
propre regard sur cette époque monsieur
de moura donc à rassembler plusieurs
lycées pour les faire travailler sur les
commémorations du centenaire
donc vous avez beaucoup de dessins qui
ont été faits et qui ont été faits par
thèmes ainsi vous avez ce souvenir
combattre souffrir et c'est avec des
des dessins en rapport un travail de
mémoire de partage entre les générations
bien accompli les jeunes les blinois
aussi travailler une pièce de théâtre
pour accompagner l'exposition le grand
festin sème les 10 novembre à 20h30 à
l'espace jean racine nouveau volet à
présent de notre dossier consacré cette
semaine aux déserts médicaux après les
constats les solutions entre réforme du
numerus clausus regroupement des
patriciens et l'organisation de soins de
proximité
mélanie poker cette généralistes un pour
quatre mille cinq cent cinquante
habitants trappe et en zone
d'intervention prioritaire
ce médecin généraliste est arrivé en
mars dans une maison santé je cherchais
une installation en groupe parce que
j'avais travaillé souvent en râlant
médecins isolés
j'avais fait beaucoup de campagnes et
hauts bonnets à un moment ben voilà
j'avais
voulu m'installer à plusieurs pour des
raisons de
proactivité on va dire du système de
santé d'être à plusieurs ça nous permet
quand même de discuter sur des cas
difficiles à l'origine du projet ce
jeune médecin déjà praticiens sur la
ville depuis 2014
il a choisi de s'installer durablement
un projet à plus d'un million d'euros
on a eu des réponses positives au niveau
de la région et au niveau de la rsr ps
qui nous ont permis en subventionnant
une partie de l'investissement du coude
d'agrandir notre surface de cabinet
médical est d'accueillir de nouveaux
professionnels de santé des appuis
techniques municipaux et des subventions
financières à hauteur notamment de
250000 euros
du côté de l' agence régionale de santé
et de l'union régionale des
professionnels de santé
d'abord faciliter l'immobilier puisque
l'immobilier est un coût important
en ile de france et donc dans le budget
économique d'un cabinet médical qui est
quand même une petite entreprise à magny
les hameaux c'est un pôle santé qui
s'est créée à l'été 2010 8 plus de
120000 euros de travaux dans l'ancien
pmi pour accueillir les patients dans le
quartier du buisson il n'y a plus de
généralistes depuis une quinzaine
d'années en centre-ville il ya quatre
médecins ça ça doit faire cinq
équivalents temps pleins de médecins
mais dans un rayon de 200 mètres chacun
donc dans le quartier de l'hôtel de
ville
par contre ici où il y à la moitié de la
population environ 4500 habitants
il n'y a aucun generali en contact avec
la rs depuis deux ans la ville a trouvé
une solution
des consultations avancées d'un médecin
urgentiste de l'hôpital privé de trappes
il consulte chaque mercredi depuis le
mois d'octobre c'est pas la même façon
de travailler en les mêmes moyens
techniques mais c'était un partenariat
et j'ai trouvé que c'était intéressant
de pouvoir faire un poste avancé de
l'hôpital et pouvoir dépanner les gens
il faut voir les accueillir dans une
structure en avant de l'hôpital
s'il n'ya pas besoin du plateau
technique une relation ville-hôpital
aussi envisagé à plaisir la ville
actuellement en discussion avec la rs et
le département s'associe avec l' hôpital
gérontologique et médico social nous
avons un terrain qui est vraiment à
l'entrée de cet hôpital qui serait tout
à fait le terrain adéquat pour pouvoir
faire cette maison médicale un médecin
pour déjà porté le projet et ensuite je
pense que avec toute l'énergie que l'on
met en place actuellement on sent des
frémissements
il y a des médecins il ya des
gynécologues par exemple qui se sont
rapprochés de nous on a des infirmières
qui se rapprochent de nous parce qu'il
faut aussi du paramédical
on a décliné certains généralistes
aujourd'hui la maison pourrait voir le
jour d'ici deux trois ans actuellement
la ville compte huit généralistes pour
près de trente deux mille habitants
nous poursuivrons cette édition du
journal je reçois à présent laurence
alternons soir bonsoir
vous êtes réalisateur du documentaire
électrique semaine sur le groupe de
musique électro pop general electric qui
sera projeté le 13 novembre signer
c'était long cours à 18h30
juste avant le concert du groupe à
quelques pas de là ce sera au prisme à
20h30 regarder
[Musique]
alors hans altherr vous nous parler un
petit peu de ce projet de suivre ce
groupe qui existe tout de même depuis
une quinzaine d'années et dont vous
connaissez bien le leader puisque c'est
votre frère m'a tout de suite le
préciser mais vous nous parler un petit
peu de l'histoire de cette idée de base
de suivre ce groupe
moi j'ai beaucoup joué avec hervé quand
on était plus jeunes on a beaucoup joué
de musique ensemble jusqu'à nos 20 ans
moi j'ai bifurqué après j'ai fait du
journalisme de la réalisation et lui il
a continué à faire de la musique
donc on continue toujours à se voir on
joue plus de musique ensemble par contre
est d'une cinquantaine d'années il ya 3
4 ans est venue l'idée la fin juin on se
voit tous on se voit régulièrement mais
je me suis dit qu'après tout je
connaissais pas si bien sa vie de
musicien que ça et puis je pense que
c'était aussi un moyen pour nous de
passer un moment ensemble et donc on je
vais proposer l'idée du film est très
vite s'est imposée l'idée à moi de alors
dans le film il est question aussi de
nous deux mais plutôt plutôt que de
mettre l'accent là dessus de de regarder
des musiciens on travaille donc en fait
de suivre un petit peu toutes les étapes
de la création avec hervé au premier
plan puisque c'est le personnage
principal même si les raisons du film et
donc on les voit dans la tournée on les
voit dans leur répétition alors on est
voire de leurs répétitions pour préparer
la tournée on les voit dans la tournée
on les voit en studio d'enregistrement
pour préparer le prochain disque pendant
qu'ils sont toujours en train de tourner
donc c'est une espèce de boucle sur la
création et le travail musical aussi un
peu comment le travail en studio se
transforme ensuite pour passer sur scène
alors c'est le contraire on suit la tour
on suit les répétitions la tournée et le
travail en studio du prochain disque
mais on voit pas le live entre
guillemets du prochain disque est ce que
vous avez appris que vous me connaissiez
pas justement à propos de cette histoire
musicale est son parcours
votre frère
ce que j'ai appris ce qui m'a
ce qui est très compliqué quand on
canton
quand on est réalisateur de
documentaires et qu'on filme l'intime
canton quand on fait du documentaire on
va vers l'inconnu et quand on va vers
l'inconnu passé on utilise la caméra en
fait comme un truchement pour pouvoir
les pour aller rencontrer l'autre et
c'est c'est assez simple à faire
entraîneur parce qu'on connaît pas
l'autre donc on le rencontre par contre
c'est plus compliqué enfin pour moi ça a
été plus compliqué de filmer quelqu'un
que je connaissais à savoir mon frère et
son environnement et donc au départ je
me suis pas mal fait avoir c'est à dire
en filmant des choses que je considérais
enfin comme je connais un tout petit peu
le milieu j'ai pas forcément été assez
naïve dans mon regard
donc disons que les choses qui m'ont
surprise entre guillemets j'dirais c'est
la routine au final quelque part la
routine au final de ce que c'est qu'une
tournée
oui parce que vous avez décrit au tout
début en introduction ça semble assez
assez routinier on monte sur scène on
pense aux albums d'après on prépare on
répète il ya des rythmes comme dans la
routine de la tournée la routine de la
tournée se dire que ça très clairement
il ya un rythme qui est imprimé
on termine le concert orange on monte
dans tour bus on repart le lendemain on
se lève à 11 heures et c est ça le bas
donc là il ya cet aspect là qui est
toujours cassé par le concert qui parce
que chaque concert est unique et ça
c'est quelque chose d'assez étonnant
c'est de voir les musiciens retrouver
enfin vivre en quelque sorte sur scène
alors qu'ils vivent une journée quand
même assez de déplacement qui au final
fini par se répéter pas mal an plis sont
très assistée on leur sert à manger etc
c'est pas un grand groupe mais ça arrive
très vite ça quand vous êtes quand vous
tournez est donc ce côté on est vivant
et on est sur scène ça c'est assez
épatant avoir certes chaque soir est
différent chaque soir est vraiment est
différente et il ne se lasse pas de ça
donc ça a été quelque chose que j'ai
découvert effectivement je pensais que
ce serait beaucoup plus routinier sur
l'aspect scénique sur l'aspect répétitif
et en fait non il arrive à renouveler ça
à chaque fois et ça fait partie du
métier pour de trouver le de trouver
l'énergie pour renouveler fin c'était
assez différent du travail que vous
aviez pu mener sur les autres
documentaires j'en étais fier d'autres
auparavant sur la relation travail par
exemple le contexte de performance etc
on est dans un registre très différent
alors je continue à regarder le travail
ce sont des musiciens au travail donc
c'était un petit peu le point de vue que
j'ai adopté parce qu'en fait je savais
pas trop comment approcher la chose au
départ donc c'est comme ça que j'ai fait
après oui c'est un milieu qui est très
très différent enfin je veux dire on
n'est pas c'est un milieu qui et je
dirai en fait qui est qui qui comme
comme tous les milieux de travail
c'est-à-dire il ya un aspect
d'aliénation le mot est un peu fort mais
enfin voilà que le routinier on
l'utilisait de tout à l'heure et puis il
ya des aspects plus brillant plus voilà
avec une différence quand même c'est que
ce sont des gens qui ont tous choisi ce
qu'ils font par passion
donc ils sont quand même conduit par sa
voix là je dirais que c'est peut-être ça
la différence à qui mieux que j'ai
exploré avancé que c'est des gens qui
sont fait un choix qu'on fait un choix
très fort et qui sont conduits par leur
passion et qui vivent leur passion
on regarde un petit extrait justement
pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas ce
groupe qui pourtant existe depuis une
quinzaine d'années et qui s'est produit
avec de nombreux artistes on peut citer
m aussi par exemple ils sont assez
proches voilà on regarde un petit
extrait puis on parlera de votre travail
encore ensuite sur le documentaire
[Musique]
oh
voilà pour le groupe que vous pourrez
découvrir sur scène le 13 novembre à
elancourt juste avant le documentaire
pour en savoir encore un petit peu plus
ce documentaire il a été difficile à
monter vous avez réalisé du crowfunding
notamment financement parcours funding
pour le réaliser ça peut être évident
les chaînes de télé les grands les
grands réseaux en fait maintenant sortie
de serge gainsbourg et de david bowie
c'est très très compliqué de leur ford
c'est considéré comme un film musical
il n'ya pas alors il ya de la musique
dans le film n'y en a pas tant que ça je
dirais qu'une vingtaine de minutes de
musique sur un film qui dure une heure
45 et 1 pas de temps que ça je croyais
beaucoup de scènes voilà de de vie tout
simplement dans le bus dans la tournée
le studio mais c'est très compliqué
quand le groupe est pas très connue de
trouver de l'argent pour monter le film
donc on a pu le monter en partie car
c'était difficile puisque ça nous a
permis un financement du cnc
et puis grâce à une opération de
crowdfunding effectivement qui nous a
permis de lever 20000 euros
mais je suis pas sûr que je
recommencerai ça c'est fait c'était
c'était assez difficile sa demande
en fait ça demande beaucoup de beaucoup
de beaucoup de temps c'est assez
chronophage et puis on n oublie moi je
suis réalisateur je peux juste aux
producteurs mais quand on est
réalisateur on est un peu obligé de
s'impliquer là dedans et j'ai alors moi
je suis tout à fait reconnaissants à
toutes les personnes qui ont financé le
projet mais je les fais pour cette fois
et c'est très heureux mais je suis pas
sûr que le recommencerais et pour
conclure vous avez prévu demain un
volume deux peut-être sur le sur le
groupe non je ne pense pas non non il y
aura pas de volume qu'il ya d'autres
projets sur la musique n'y aura pas de
volume de votre frère non tout va bien
avec votre frère trois temps ce sera à
découvrir en attendant le concert donc
ce sera à 20h30 au prisme à elancourt
général elektriks et puis électrique
même le documentaire et qui est consacré
au ciné cette a et l'encours 18h30
l'entrée est libre pour le documentaire
elle les places sont encore disponibles
pour le concert tous les renseignements
se sont affichés comme d'habitude sur
votre écran merci laurence interdit de
passer sur notre plateau comme chaque
mercredi à présent petit détour par les
salles de cinéma de saint quentin pour
un point sur les sorties ciné
[Musique]
l'actualité au cinéma les yeux d'elsa
c'est notre réouverture après huit
semaines de fermeture suite à un dégât
des eaux qui avaient abîmé la moquette
et les sièges de la salle
nous avons tourné toyer le haut la
moquette les sièges et on va pouvoir
vous accueillir dans un cinéma qui sent
le neuf pour récupérer les films qu'on
avait prévu de programmer qu'on vous
avait proposé puis qu'on a été obligé
d'annuler à cause de ce dégât des eaux
donc vous pourrez redécouvrir des films
sur grand écran comme les vieux
fourneaux première année mais aussi les
frères sister's de jacques audiard qui
est un vrai film fort un des grands
films de cette fin d'année 2010 8
jacques audiard étant un des grands
réalisateurs français actuellement en
activité
c'est quelqu'un qui travaille sur les
relations entre les hommes la fraternité
et cetera depuis regarde les hommes
tomber son premier film avec frontignan
4 bis
il n'a cessé de travailler cette matière
là des relations entre hommes de la
fraternité au sein de souvent d'histoire
assez difficile et assez complexe le
western semble lui aller très très bien
je vous invite donc à venir le découvrir
et puis on aura aussi sur la question la
fraternité de manière plus concrète et
contemporaine et commémorative en même
temps les croix de bois
adapté du roman de raymond dorgelès
qu'on vous propose de découvrir en
version restaurée
le samedi 10 novembre à 16 heures et on
aura une petite un petit bonus en début
de projection d'un court métrage
d'époque de 1915
je vous invite donc à revenir aussi des
maldives d'elsa nous sommes réouvert à
très bientôt un mot de ce sport à
présent et plus précisément de course à
pied 12e édition de l'eco-trail paris le
17 mars prochain toujours au départ de
lille de loisirs à saint quentin en
yvelines le tracé a été présenté
officiellement hier depuis un salon de
la tour eiffel ou mickaël millero n'a
pas manqué de se rendre dès trail en
pleine nature et des coureurs qui vont
au bout d'eux-mêmes voici le programme
de la 12e édition de l'eco-trail le
rendez-vous proposera le 17 mars des
courses de 18 30 45 et 80 km entre
l'ouest parisien et la tour eiffel plus
de douze mille participants sont
attendus sur cette épreuve
c'est devenu le plus gros rendez-vous
trail de début de saison où on peut
accueillir des élites les meilleures
élites de la discipline et c'est aussi
en fonction des différentes des
différents formats de course de 18 aux
80 c'est hyper ouvert ce qui fait que
les gens on en a de plus en plus qui
s'inscrivent de plus en plus tôt donc
nous nous inscrivions dès le mois de
juillet ça veut dire que près de neuf
mois avant avant l'événement et on est
complet
on est complet au mois de février parmi
les participants fabien parmentier un
coureur originaire de montigny le
bretonneux le runner a déjà participé à
11 édition de l'eco trail et repartir à
cette année sur le 80 km le départ est à
quelques kilomètres de chez moi
et puis ça permet surtout à ma famille
de me suivre en fait sur sur la totalité
du parcours
donc voilà c'est ma course le cas là moi
quoi avec le temps fabien parmentier
connaît parfaitement les pièges à éviter
sur ce départ à domicile depuis l'île de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
faut se mettre dedans officiellement
faut rentrer dans la course retrouver le
bon rythme faut éviter de passes faire
d'entorse parce qu'effectivement on part
sur la base de loisirs de saint quentin
et puis on part dans un une espèce de
chant qui est relativement beau ce n'est
pas évident pour les scheer donc faut
faire fort à ses attentes il faut
trouver le bon rythme parce se cramer
trop vite
une stratégie qui l'aidera peut-être à
réaliser son objectif boucler cet ultra
trail avec un temps compris entre 8h30
et 9h30 sport toujours et c'est
quasiment officiel l'ancien trappistes
nicolas anelka va rejoindre le banc du
losc en ligue 1 l'ancien attaquant du
psg de chelsea devrait encadrer les
jeunes et peut-être les attaquants du
club le journal revient à demain 18h en
direct avec grégory canal et à bientôt
[Musique]